Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us for our 10th FUWAMOCO Morning!
10!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
Well, for those who are joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, Monday.
Yeah, FUWAMOCO.
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO.
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please make sure you tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
Okay?
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, what do we have in store for today?
We've heard from you directly that there's been another Pero Sighting.
Another Pero Sighting.
Where is this one?
De-den.
Pero.
He's in a beautiful open field.
Look at the sky, Moco-chan.
It's a pretty nice sky.
It's nice and blue.
I like a good blue sky.
Maybe Pero's just been craving some fresh open air and nature recently.
Yeah, I mean, does this count as nature?
There's not much trees.
True, but you know, I also kind of get a bit of a nostalgic feeling looking at a tree, you know?
Maybe it feels a bit personal.
Like a personal computer, maybe?
It has a computer feeling to it.
It's kind of unsettling, though.
It doesn't look very natural.
Pero!
We're gonna find you!
We'll get you!
Scary when you say it like that, Moco-chan.
Ruffians!
Ruffians, you'll help us find him, okay?
Right?
I don't know, you know.
Tomorrow we're gonna go to the back rooms, right?
Maybe there's some computers in the back rooms.
I don't think I want that.
I hope the back room looks more like this.
Hopefully he's still there since we're gonna go and try to find him.
Ruffians, please let us know if you have any more sightings.
Use the hashtag, okay?
Hashtag FWMCMORNING, okay?
But to be honest though, I am kind of worried that we aren't going to be able to find him in the back room.
He should still be there.
Right.
It's his new house.
What do you think, Ruffians?
How did he get inside the windows?
I'm not sure.
We don't know.
He just... He sent us a photo, you know.
Maybe if we find him, we can ask him.
It's an idea.
Let's do it, okay, Ruffians?
Well, Ruffians, you might already know, but just in the past few days, there's been something extra special that happened.
De-den!
It was a very very special Precious Senpai Council's second anniversary!
I drew a special drawing of them.
Right?
His cute Moco-chan looks just like them.
What do you think, Ruffians?
Well, we wanted to wish them a very happy second anniversary!
We can't believe that it's already been two years.
Right?
Ruffians, does it feel like it's been two years?
Well, you know, there's been a lot of funny moments, and so many good memories, yeah.
Good memories made along the way.
And the cake!
Ruffians, you saw the cake the council made all together, right?
It looks so good!
But my cake looks better, right?
Does it?
It's bigger!
That's for sure, it's bigger.
You need a big cake for four people.
Well, you know, and then...
They also announced the 3D showcases!
We're looking forward to it so much!
We know just how hard Senpai has been working to prepare for them.
I'm looking forward to it.
Ruffians, you better look forward to it too!
Let's all have fun, okay?
We hope we can get to know them a bit more closely soon after too.
Make more memories all together.
Happy Anniversary, Cats!
BAU BAU!
And!
In case you didn't know.
There's something we wanted to remind you.
Yeah!
Reminder!
Very important.
Advent!
It's almost been a month since we debuted.
And to mark our debut as members of hololive, you know, there's been some special debut celebration merchandise.
You didn't forget, right?
Right!
Right, I know it's already been almost a month.
But yes, the window for pre-orders is going to be coming to a close very soon.
On the 4th.
September 4th.
Make sure you don't forget, okay?
Because this will be the only time you can get them.
And you know, I know it can be a bit frustrating.
A bit like, ah!
I want them in my paws right now!
It can take some time, but it's well worth the wait.
And you know, they're limited.
You might never be able to get them again, so... It's just Extra Special, right?
And this way, you know, you'll be like, well, I was with  from the start, at the very, the very start of the journeys, right?
So... Extra Special!
We hope that you check them out if you haven't yet!
And actually, you haven't been able to have a peek yet, but we had a bit of a peek at the sample.
They create like magnets too.
You know sometimes like magnets will fall off the fridge and then they break?
Not the type.
No.
And I was thinking, you know, like, Moco-chan, I can hold up maybe one side of a Ruffian's photo and then you can hold the other one up and we can like, teamwork it!
Right?
Magnets.
Yeah!
Also there's the stained glass kitchen there you just saw.
I was thinking, you know, for maybe
Maybe Ruffians are a bit more fashionable into the aesthetic things.
You could hang it off your nose.
You could.
Or you know, maybe you want to show your love for Advent on a boat.
But you're maybe a little shy too, you could put it on your bike.
Ah, choo!
Right.
Yeah?
And then there's also the acrylic stands too!
Ruffians, do you know what you're gonna do with them yet?
Where you're gonna place them?
How you're gonna use them?
There's lots of different ways to arrange acrylic stands.
I wanna see it!
We're looking forward to it.
Maybe Ruffians, you can take photos afterwards and share it with us.
I'm curious.
Stick us on a journey.
We can go on a walk together!
I'll wear them like earrings.
That was very creative.
Please check them out!
Thank you!
Well, you know, we especially wanted to remind you about the merch.
But that's because we really like merch, too.
And I know we haven't really talked about it much before, but I sort of wanted to talk about it.
There's one thing that we both really, really like.
Well, we like a lot of different kinds of merch.
Yeah, we like a lot of stuff.
Especially, especially this.
We really like figures and garage kits.
There might be some Ruffians that don't know what garage kits are, so we'll explain that.
But figures.
Scale figures.
Particularly we like scale figures.
At one point, we had well over a hundred of them, but, you know... Things happen when we're in the cell and they're...
Somewhere out there.
But our favorite figure scales are 1-7 scale and above.
But I feel like larger figures are just getting more popular recently.
But there's way too many super cute figures nowadays.
It's just really, really dangerous.
Dangerous, dangerous.
But I think we're good at avoiding temptation.
Just look.
Right?
Avoid it.
Ruffians, do you like figures?
Do you have figures?
One for scale!
That's when it's serious.
Serious business.
It's not an addiction.
100 figures is completely reasonable, okay?
You do.
If you love them all equally, then... Well, I think there might be some more that you like more than others.
But my favorite sculptor is Morikawa Hiromitsu.
But they don't really do many figures anymore nowadays.
But I just really like them because they're really good with round faces and capturing the character's personality through their simple but cute poses.
I like...
I think simple is good.
You know, once I really capture the character's personality, it brings them to life.
You guys have been in storage for a long time.
It's tough.
It's tough, you know?
Toshindai!
Wait, not Ohesou.
Just Toshindai.
The full life-size Toshindai.
Very, very good.
That's made of dreams.
I think there's a lot of Ruffians maybe that might wonder like...
Oh, but one of these figures is good because they just sit there.
No, no.
That's what makes them so good.
They sit there.
They're just happy.
You can look at them from every kind of angle.
They're beautiful.
Beautiful.
Admire them.
Yeah.
You know, they're always smiling back at you.
You can see from all different, like maybe close up, maybe from far away.
Maybe in bright light, maybe in dark light.
You know, in the sunshine from the morning.
Or the sunset, you know.
It's great.
I'm seeing a comment that I do not agree with.
Kind of creepy.
No!
It's beautiful.
It's artwork.
And it stays forever and ever.
We also really really like...
Pink Cadillac and Bome for the garage kits.
So garage kits!
They're like figures that you have to assemble and paint yourself.
But usually resin.
Yeah, yeah.
We've never built a kit before.
But I really, really admire people that can build kits.
It seems really intimidating having to pin all the parts together and sand and airbrush and all this stuff.
Yeah.
And then it's like, what if you make a little mistake?
Having to repaint it again is very, very amazing.
But I think it's something that we'd like to do one day.
When we're very, very, very old guard dogs.
Hopefully we'll still have very good vision then, Moco-chan, right?
I didn't think about that.
Hopefully we'll have very nimble fingers too.
And hopefully the resin will still hold up then too.
Another hope is maybe Moco-chan, one day we can become figures too.
And then that way we can be with you Ruffians wherever you go!
Watch you all the time!
Right?
Even when you don't realize it.
I'll watch you when you sleep!
Yeah!
Wish you like that!
Yes!
Not creepy!
It's not creepy!
Totally normal.
I don't forget.
If you don't have a figure yet, one day.
Can you promise that your first figure is going to be FUWAMOCO?
I think it's a good suggestion.
Yes!
A good suggestion.
Oh, one, one Pero figure.
I would like that.
It won't be very soft.
It won't be.
That's okay.
Thank you, Ruffians!
Okay, it's a promise then.
A promise.
Okay.
And...
I think it's time for the Ruffians' favorite part of FUWAMOCO Morning.
De-den!
And for today, it's... De-den!
Actually, Moco-chan, actually!
There's something that I wanted to clear up.
Ruffians!
I have something important to say.
Oh, this?
Yeah.
Ruffians!
You know, sometimes Moco-chan, you ask for praise from the Ruffians, right?
You know, like, praise me or, you know, am I cute?
Or, can I get head pads?
Those kind of things, right?
Recently it's been more and more and more.
I don't know about that.
It's not like it's been a problem or anything, but... Are you sure?
It sure sounds like it's a problem.
You haven't been bothered by Moco-chan, right?
Am I just a bother?
Huh?
Huh, Ruffians?
Right?
But, but, but... I know... I know...
Moco-chan, you know, she's my little sister, and I need to be like a stronger, older sister for her, right?
You know, like a good role model!
Right?
Yeah.
So, I've let her be a little bit more needy from you Ruffians, but... I wanted to say that... that Fuwawa likes to be praised too.
You know, I've been trying to be strong, you know, and I've been trying to put on a brave face too.
And Moco-chan is needy because I have to be the older sister, but I like to be praised by the Ruffians too, so... Me too.
Don't forget about me, okay?
Okay.
That's all.
I'm Mococo.
Huh?
Oh, I'm Mococo.
Moco-chan.
You're good.
You got a lot of hepatoplasm, you know.
You should try to be a bit more like your older sister.
Right.
What?
I'm Mococo!
No misunderstandings today.
Ruffians, you understand right.
Understand my feelings?
Next!
Thanks, Moco-chan.
Thanks for giving me that special moment to clear up the misunderstanding.
You're welcome!
Wow!
Today's the 10th episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
We didn't give you much time there.
We wanted to ask something extra special for a musically talented Ruffians.
We're looking for a musical jingle for FUWAMOCO Morning!
You know, um...
It's nothing, you say special, but it's nothing too special.
It's something, you know, quick and simple.
Something less than 10 seconds.
Less than 10 seconds.
It could be like a BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Or like a BAUI!
You know, but we'd like to ask, you know, that it's completely original, like an original melody, and that you don't use any copyrighted sounds or voice clips in it.
But like, if you wanted to use Moco-chan's squeaky BAU BAU just now, you could.
I wouldn't recommend it.
You know...
It's something that just says, FUWAMOCO Morning!
Yeah, yeah, whenever you feel like that.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And then we'll be like, Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's FUWAMOCO Morning!
Yeah.
I think we have different ideas, Moco-chan, but that's okay!
That's fine!
I wanna know what the Ruffians think.
I wanna know from you!
Yeah!
You can submit it on Twitter with the hashtag #FWMCJINGLE.
If you'd like to ask for it in either a WAVE or MP3 format, and if you're a bit confused, you can always link it to a Google Drive.
The submission deadline is rather soon.
It's September 3rd.
Hopefully that'll be okay, Ruffians.
It's 10 seconds.
Less than 10 seconds.
Yeah, less than 10 seconds.
Not have to be 10 seconds, less than 10 seconds.
2 seconds, 3 seconds.
That's all good too, you know?
Less than 10 seconds.
No pressure.
You know something that is like, ah, I listened to this and it's another FUWAMOCO Morning.
That kind of feeling.
Yeah, that feel, you know?
You know we can start off the new day something cute.
That kind of thing.
Energy.
Not heavy.
We're really really looking forward to growing FUWAMOCO Morning into something even bigger all together with you Ruffians.
No pressure.
No pressure, no pressure.
I don't know so much of the ooze ooze thing that Moco-chan's thinking of.
I don't know, maybe that's some Ruffians idea.
Don't give them ideas, let them think on their own.
You're the one who started it, Moco-chan.
What?
I didn't start anything.
You did, you did.
No?
Ruffians!
Do you recognize these?
Do you recognize that?
These question marks.
You saw them recently.
Well, you don't!
We took a look at our schedule.
We have our 500k Ruffians on YouTube celebration!
We're gonna have a really big party this weekend.
But you noticed the question, question, question mark beside it, right?
Right.
I think some Ruffians did.
Do you have any ideas what that could be?
It's not a B-A-U.
It's not a BAU.
No.
But the BAU BAU is always included.
Yeah.
Not pizza.
Pizza's how many letters?
Four?
Five?
Five letters?
No.
That doesn't make sense.
It doesn't.
Ruffians, do you wanna know?
Do you wanna know?
You'll be at the celebration regardless of what it is, right?
Right!
Right.
I thought we let you know now!
De-den!
We're gonna be opening memberships!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
It's happening, Ruffians!
We're opening our memberships, doing our 500k celebration.
Ruffians, we hope that you'll be there with us!
We're really really looking forward to spending more time together and trying lots of different things with the membership too.
We thought it'd be a good time to open it.
Make a big big celebration.
Extra celebratory celebration.
You know,
But we're really looking forward to making a membership somewhere like really fun and comfy too.
Fun and comfy.
We hope that you'll think of joining membership during our celebration day.
Membership party!
Membership!
Yeah, BAU BAU.
Can't spell membership without the BAU.
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Let's have lots of fun, okay?
Don't miss it.
Okay?
BAU BAU!
We'll go on to our regular segments today.
The Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
It's Chester!
Chester!
So cute!
Chester likes sleeping, chasing cats and bunnies.
We sound sort of similar, huh?
Now that you know I'm watching FUWAMOCO Morning, we're sort of similar.
I was gonna say, he sounds like a doggy that we become the best of friends with.
Especially because he doesn't like scary things either.
We are gonna be buddies.
I like to think you know that maybe Chester has like a very strong sixth sense.
You know, like if he senses me... I don't know about you, but like if he senses something there, like he's gone.
He's out of there.
No, I'm a tough... tough... I'm tough, yes.
Moco-chan's not the type to run away.
I would never run away, right?
Never ever ever.
I was saying though, like...
Some people might not think, you know, a guard dog is good if it guards you.
But if it runs away, then you know to run with it.
Safety alarm dog.
You can run all the way together as fast as you can.
I think that's good.
What do you think, Ruffians?
Safety in another way.
A different kind of guard dog.
You shouldn't have thought, Biboo!
No, this is Chester.
I don't know if Biboo's quite that cute.
Oh no.
Biboo's gonna walk us if we're not careful.
I said nothing.
Well, how does Chester go?
I kind of feel like maybe Chester has a very good, solid voice.
But it's maybe kind of typical, like a BAU BAU.
BAU BAU.
A typical BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, BAU BAU!
I love Biboo too.
Biboo is cute.
Just maybe not as much as Chester.
Today, I went on a walk.
What kind of walk did we go on today?
De-den!
It's kind of like the winter.
What?
It's just a bit different.
It's like where Pero is.
Right!
A bit similar.
This is Britain!
Britain!
There's a skate well too.
That's fun.
And traditional fish and chip shop.
The park was fun.
Extra Ruffian.
I don't know.
Dangerous Park.
But, FUWAMOCO, the skate park.
Skateboarding!
We've never tried it before.
Can you imagine?
I go on it and I go... And then I would faceplant.
Yeah, we do it best just on bicycles.
But, even then, that's kind of questionable.
It's questionable.
Ruffians, I think you know
You well know that we're very afraid of anything scary, like heights.
No, we're not!
We're good, we're good, we're good!
So skateboarding, it's not really our thing.
Maybe, you know, there's the vroom vroom vroom of the wheels on the ground, you know?
Can you take responsibility for catching us when we fall?
I don't know if we can get the Ruffians though.
Oh, Ruffians are toffians!
That makes sense, I guess.
I was gonna say Ruffians though, you're probably more coordinated than us, so if you want to try skateboarding, please do it.
Try it!
Try it for us.
Fun things are fun.
As long as you don't get hurt.
As long as you don't bite us if we catch you.
As long as you catch us like a normal person.
Catch us like a normal person, you know.
No promises!
A Question of the Day.
De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
I'm a bit of a perfectionist and it leaves me feeling dejected and frustrated when I don't do things up to my mental standard.
And it's a lot harsher when it comes to creative ventures.
Do you two experience that?
Do you have any advice?
We understand.
Yeah, we used to be really, really bad perfectionists.
So yeah, we know it can be hard.
Ruffians, you too!
BAU BAU!
It's not going to be anything.
It's no good.
Because you can't expect everything to be perfect, you know?
Sometimes it's not going to be as you like it.
And that's just normal.
You just have to keep on trying.
Make stuff you don't make.
Perfect is the enemy of good, right?
And it's really... It's frustrating!
It makes me mad!
Like, why did I do that?
That was a waste of time.
We didn't need to do that.
Exactly.
So, just be... Just do your best.
Be you.
Nobody is perfect.
And like, you know, Moco-chan said, perfect is boring, you know?
And I think that it can be fun to not be perfect.
So, look forward to some...
Well, we'll talk a bit more about that, but Ruffians are always looking for more submissions for Pero Sightings, for Doggie of the Day vlogs, and for some more questions.
I think there's maybe been a couple questions about where the questions should be going.
For FUWAMOCO Morning, if you have any submissions for FUWAMOCO Morning or questions, please use the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
If you think this could be a FUWAMOCO Morning, that's where you go.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I'm sorry that was a bit confusing.
That was our fault.
We'll try to have it less confusing.
Thank you, Ruffians!
As for our next stream... De-den!
We're going to be playing Little Witch Nobeta once more!
It's been quite a while.
Well, we're after that too, but again!
Again!
Again.
You know, it's been a little while since the last one, but I was really impressed, Moco-chan, because I think compared to the beginning, you really improved.
And there's only a little bit of time.
Only a little bit.
Only a little more.
To be honest though, I'm glad I don't have to touch the keys.
It looks really difficult.
It's lazy.
No, it's not lazy.
It looks difficult.
I think it's lazy.
Instead though, I'll just, I'll enjoy the journey.
And you know, I'll tell Moco-chan what to do when she needs me to.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's have lots of FUWAMOCO-yans!
Our schedule!
Again!
We have a 500k celebration!
And our memberships are opening too!
Membership!
I can't wait.
But you know, there's also the Extra Rare Rock n' Rawr Party.
Yeah.
This time it's an archive, you know.
And we've been a bit secretive.
Secretive, maybe.
About what makes it so
Extra Special.
But, Ruffians, I think you know well, too, that we really like Japanese music.
Right!
And we know Japanese music.
But this time, we're gonna be challenging ourselves to sing a lot more of the popular hit songs from Western music.
Yeah.
So, expect... tummy hurt.
Yeah, it's gonna be something else.
Not to say there won't be any Japanese songs, but... We're gonna be laughing.
Yeah, be ready to laugh, okay?
Yeah.
It'll be interesting.
A very very different Rock'n'Roll Party.
Yeah, we don't know how many of these different Rock'n'Roll Parties there's gonna be, but it'll be very different!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for our 10th FUWAMOCO Morning.
I can't believe technically it's the 11th because there was a pilot episode, but it's the 10th episode.
Thank you Ruffians, thank you for joining us for the 10th episode of FUWAMOCO Morning.
And we know there's going to be a lot more special episodes to come, especially with maybe a brand new jingle too.
But before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Viewers today.
Everly!
BAU BAU!
David!
Otama!
BAU BAU!
Kitsune!
Sordelli!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!